alain lamballe bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france alors on l'a vu à
la tension ne faiblit pas au pakistan 11
policiers pakistanais ont été prises en
otage hier ils ont été relâchés tôt ce
matin comment comprendre que la police
du pays soit elle aussi la cible des
manifestants
des manifestants qui vise on disait la
france oui bien sûr mouvement des
mouvements extrémistes comme cela a été
souligné dans votre reportage qui est ce
mouvement extrémiste se prend à tous les
infrastructures qui dépendent de l'état
tous les organes étatiques évidemment la
police est en première ligne achat
suffit alors c'est pas un nouveau
d'ailleurs au pakistan ça secoue fumât
fou mais ça s'est produit lors de
manifestations précédentes
dans les décennies qui précède qui est
ce parti islamiste radicale intérim est
elle là bas qu'elle a aura ce qu'il est
soutenu par une partie de la population
oui incontestablement il est soutenu par
une partie de la population puisqu'il y
à des manifestations monstres et des
milliers les centaines de milliers et
même de personnes participent à ces
animations manifestations
c'est un parti relativement nouveau
c'est un parti politique en réalité ce
n'est pas une formation extrémistes
terroristes en tant que tel mais
effectivement il se manifeste de façon
violente
alors ce mot ce parti politique qui
existe depuis quelques années c'était
déjà manifesté lorsque des obsèques
avaient eu lieu de de l'assassin d'un
gouvernement pakistanais qui avait
défendu une chrétienne accusée de
blasphème et on a vu lors de ses
obsèques des centaines de milliers de
personnes
il assistait donc ce mouvement
effectivement à des des commandes est
restée sympathie dans la population
c'est incontestable et pourtant
lorsqu'il ya des élections ce parti ne
remporte pas de
comment dirais je le vois il n'a pas eu
de voix en sa faveur par exemple pour
l'élection de députés au parlement
fédéral
néanmoins ce parti a des députés dans
l'assemblée provinciale du sind
alors ces manifestations elles sont pas
nouvelles elles montrent notamment à il
ya environ cinq mois mais pourquoi
aujourd'hui il y a un regard de cette
mobilisation de ces protestations contre
la france tout simplement parce qu'il y
avait eu un accord entre ce mouvement et
il paie et le gouvernement selon lequel
des débats devaient avoir lieu au
parlement fédéral au sujet de
l'expulsion de l'ambassadeur de france
comme le débat parlementaire tardait et
bien ce mouvement tlp a préféré devancer
finalement les débats qui n'aboutissent
et qui n'avait même pas commencé a
préféré donc lancer des mouvements
populaires et dans les grandes villes le
pakistanais alors quelle est la position
du gouvernement parce qu'on a entendu un
samedi le premier ministre pakistanais a
déclaré que les pays occidentaux
devaient punir ceux qui insultent le
prophète mahomet comme ceux qui nient la
shoah et puis en même temps les
policiers on l'a vu son sont la cible un
de ces manifestants
quelle est la position du gouvernement
pakistanais on a le sentiment qu'elle a
un milieu un peu ambigu vous avez tout à
fait raison le sentiment l'action de
l'attitude du gouvernement à accélérer
tout à fait ambigu dans le passé est
d'ailleurs le premier ministre a plus ou
moins forte avec des partis islamistes
légaux mais quand même ma styliste
il a même flirté avec les talibans nous
une certaine manière elle aurait il été
il a effectivement une position ambiguë
parce que il se rend compte qu'une
partie de la population soutient le plp
par l'ensemble de la population bien
évidemment mais quand même une partie
non négligeable de la population de
soutien s'était elle paie alors pour
calmer un petit peu le jeu eh bien il
s'adresse aux pays occidentaux en leur
disant bec été respectée le prophète
n'acceptait pas que des caricatures du
prophète soit reproduite dans les médias
il essaye de calmer le jeu de cette
manière c'était un message adressé aux
gouvernements occidentaux mais aussi
adressé bien sûr que la population
pakistanaise alors des diplomates
français à qui on était
rappelé par le quai d'orsay qu'est ce
que ça signifie d'un point de vue
diplomatique justement dans ce contexte
il y avait effectivement bien sûr un
ralentissement des relations
diplomatiques mais ceci dit notre
ambassadeur est toujours en place à bas
à vrai dire le gouvernement pakistanais
qui ne tient absolument pas bien sûr à
la rupture des relations diplomatiques
il est important pour le pakistan
d'avoir des relations commerciales avec
la france elle ne sont pas négligeables
et dans le domaine militaire et bien il
y à des experts français qui assure la
maintenance des matériels que nous avons
vendus au pakistan notamment des mirage
mais aussi des sous marins donc le
pakistan ne veut absolument pas rompre
les relations diplomatiques que le
gouvernement pakistanais mais il est
certain que les relations diplomatiques
ne sert plus ne se font plus haut niveau
maximum puisqu'il depuis plus d'un an
maintenant il n'y a pas d'ambassadeur du
pakistan à paris l'ambassadeur du
pakistan à paris a été nommé il ya plus
d'un an à pékin et son remplaçant n'a
toujours pas été désigné donc pas
l'ambassadeur du pakistan à dash est ce
que les ressortissants français qui sont
aujourd'hui au pakistan on le rappelle
le gouvernement français les a appelés à
quitter le pays est ce qu'aujourd'hui on
peut dire qu'ils sont en grand danger ou
alors est ce qu ils peuvent bénéficier
malgré tout la protection du
gouvernement pakistanais ils ne seront
pas forcément en danger immédiat mais
ceci dit ces français au nombre de
quelques centaines ne sont pas de
menacer directement messages edi sont
bien sûr dispersés dans la ville d'ys
thomas d ailleurs il est possible que la
police les protègent de certaine manière
mais c'est une protection relativement
inefficace ceci dit le danger n'est
quand même pas immédiat je suis dit le
gouvernement français a préféré jouer de
la prudence et on le comprend très bien
en incitant les ressortissants français
rejoint aussi possible la france mais
tous n'ont pas répondu à cet appel de
lausanne merci beaucoup alain lamballe
pour votre éclairage ce matin dans la
matinale je rappelle que vous êtes
spécialiste de l'asie du sud au centre
français de recherche sur le
renseignement également contributeurs à
sylvain terre